you need to wait down
what's with the jeans so he's hanging
out with some pimps and is in this thing
and he does you know from the front of
pineapple to the Big Apple you know they
all have little expressions and and
things that rhyme but here this is him
doing it this is white folks doing his
little pimp rhyme
hey Trey hey cuz my Pippin is on the
loose and now there's you know the whole
gotta do is be the motherfucking
composer leader is that you that does
sound like you I wish you guys could
play timer black together like the two
of you oh man he would I think he would
he would I don't know hurry game but
your black is really good
can we hear his black again and then you
say the same phrase here's the here's
the second part here okay
he does another one you know what I'm
saying yeah you know I'm always in
motion just like the ocean all the best
got to do is come on drink some of my
pubes little potion that ones tear
stupid that was so funny the guy would
write something that dumb that's so dumb
I got the motion of the ocean yeah yeah
drink my that was like early rap when
when I when they when the rapper you be
like what what rhymes with lotion right
ocean ration motion you start listening
like I listen to back spend a lot on
yeah XM and every once in a while you're
here when were you go how did this get
recorded I mean my girl
we're rubbing the lotion and all she can
do would think about swimming in the
ocean you like this made it you had a
record deal with that like that's
horrible that was awesome back then
though no one was writing that no one
had rhymed words public like mr. Troy my
folks that's his yeah Wednesday by the
try a comes my Pippin is only loose and
our needs and all ho God do is be the
motherfucking composer song he does it
it's very uh you could tell that he
holds the air and his jazz you know a
beat of muhfuckas phone like he does Wow
whoa Wow
mr. white folks is that your mr. white
phone that was my folks here's the thing
wow that's
game it's Tom or black or white folks
which now there's two there's a lot see
that's so easy to play Tom or black it's
too easy and this shit should be easy
it's just amazing
yeah so that is exactly how oh wow
so Tom or black or mr. white folks now
yep this recipe yeah it's not easy with
no mr. landfill no or mr. white folks
wow that's such a good game but some is
the white phone high-fives and all the
whole got a doobie my fucking boots
hey Wednesday by the track hey cuz my
Pippin is on the loose and I'm dancing
all the ho got to do is be the
motherfucking composer leader you know
yeah yeah yeah I bet whenever he walks
out of the room they're like he's
fucking wakeful yes of course
most definitely cuz this guy's really
you know what saying he'd be trying to
perpetrate like he's a brother and he's
you know I'm saying it's not I'm like
you know what I'm saying
yeah he's not he's not you know this is
fine oh oh this reminds me of Brent
Weinbach when he was a substitute
teacher at the black kid okay missus
it's like the easiest nickname yes
whatever the obvious no yeah oh there
you are
what's up mister pants this is like mr.
white folks yeah hey mister pants put
your pants on
yeah look at you with Japan oh that's
the best that is the best